le bio c'est une évidence benjamin
trousses l'art baigne dans cette
agriculture depuis ses 4 ans aujourd'hui
installé à son compte il défend sa
production coûte que coûte mise à rude
épreuve ces derniers mois il faut dire
que son chiffre d'affaires a baissé
jusqu'à 40% je veux pas mal armés sur ce
chiffre là parce qu'on ne serait ce qu
en allant faire ses courses ou en
sortant en ville aujourd'hui on sent
bien que les gens sont moins dehors
aussi donc je pense que c'est un effet
général qui n'est pas lié qu'à
l'agriculture bio
c'est pas un dévoiement de l'agriculture
bio par les clients c'est pas un
renoncement à cette consommation là je
pense que c'est simplement la
consommation qui tend à se tendre un
petit peu donc charge à nous de remettre
en valeur notre mode de production et de
remettre en valeur le monde si ses
fruits et légumes sont concernés ils ne
sont pas les seuls le beurre bio
enregistre une baisse de consommation de
12% sur l'année 2000 21 18 pour la
farine la raison principale de leur prix
alors que le coût de la vie des français
ne cesse d'augmenter mais un prix qui
s'explique par la main d'oeuvre plus
conséquente pour autant l'agriculteur ne
changera pas
dès le premier jour d'installation j'ai
réussi à être en bio
où je pourrais pas faire autrement et ça
n'arrangerait pas les choses parce
qu'aujourd'hui
enfin
je les gens viennent pour la qualité de
mes produits viennent parce que je suis
en bio viennent pour mes convictions par
mac à petit ma compétence à leur
partager ça on dénombre aujourd'hui 1720
exploitations biologiques en centre val
de loire si les professionnels concernés
s'en détourner l'objectif national de 18
% de surfaces agricoles bio d'ici 2027
serait compromis